primetime special Conan in Israel is
airing tomorrow that airs tomorrow
September 19th at 10 o'clock p.m. in
prime time right here on TBS I went I
went to many places in Israel I had a
lot of adventures here's just a little
taste Here I am in the Dead Sea take a
look
wow I can feel my body changing all the
salt my penis has been turned into a
brined Vlasic pickle are you here with
your boyfriend no okay you're with me
now
I took off my wedding ring they said you
can't wear jewelry here I'm not married
while I'm in the Dead Sea
why are you covered in this mud you
think methyl the Dead Sea because those
minerals and stuff you put it all over
your body is this attractive do I look
at wracked ofnow attractive Israeli man
more attractive than without them I know
so you think I'm more attractive covered
in mud then as God made me I'm gonna go
that way and I'm going to cry
she's just flirting with me you can tell
to see it all be sure to watch our
primetime special Conan in Israel airing
tomorrow September 19th at 10 o'clock
p.m. ends tomorrow and check out all of
the many and there are a lot many Conan
in Israel extras at Team Coco comm /
Israel we'll see you then
you